it's literally like breathing it's
important but it's the bare minimum i
think that women don't actually like
nice guys because then why do we hate
men
being nice is
what the [ __ ] does that do for me if
you're nice i'm like no i'm saying like
like you always hear women say men are
trash if they weren't sleeping with the
trash men why would they say that that
is true
then i'll trust you i don't so
but but like you think that why because
you've probably slept with some men that
are trash that aren't nice that's what
i'm saying i don't think
that i don't think women actually like
nice guys yeah i i don't think men are
well i'm pansexual so this makes a lot
more sense to people i'm pansexual um i
think
i don't i don't actually think men are
trash because i've got a lot of good men
in my life but um
it's more that well this is but then i'm
like this is on me if i'm choosing to
engage and entertain yeah i if i choose
to engage and entertain in like men that
i i'll say i'm like i don't feel
respected by you and i'm like then amy
you can walk away you can walk away if
you don't respect it it's on you if
you're breaking your own heart and hurt
your own feelings yeah so i'm like i'm
very wise and like i'm
uh i can't say wise but i'm like
like i'm aware enough to be like this is
on you girl like you could you could
yeah oh i think i take a lot of
accountability i'm like yeah like no i
agree i always say like it's my own
fault if like i'm in a situation i
shouldn't be and i'm like it's my fault
yeah and well but like as but then as a
woman we'd like expect just i've been
cheating so i've only been in love maybe
twice in my adult life and both of those
men cheated on me
and i was like okay at the end of the
day cheating isn't right if you're not
happy you can leave and i was like
however
i do recognize that maybe i know one of
them was actually like a complete like
narcissistic psychopath he lied about
having cancer he told me he had a cancer
he didn't and i was like you're actually
a bad person
but one of them was a really nice guy
who was really in love with me and he
cheated on me and i was like
i understand that it's because i wasn't
giving him enough i understand i
actually understand that there was part
of my i was partly responsible for him
being miserable
but
um
but he he's a good guy that did a bad
thing because he was like
he took responsibility he's a good guy
and he faked cancer no no no no no no no
no no no no no
the cancer faker
he was like he was gaslight 101 and i
okay i fell for it and i stayed with him
he cheated on me like relentlessly yeah
this other guy everyone was like
sometimes i'm like how do you have the
time
but this other guy he was like
so in love with me
and so when he cheated on me it really
impacted a lot of people because people
like we don't know who you are right now
because you were really in love with amy
and you cheated on her
and i'm like i think he cheated on me
because i and i still think it really
stems from me because i wasn't able to
accept his love i wasn't able to and i
think he got to a point where he was
like
when am i going to be enough when am i
going to be able to prove to her that
why is he i don't understand like
you weren't accepting his love what does
that mean
um i think it comes from like like
trauma like
like what do you mean by like exactly
because when i hear i can accept his
love
i think i'm worthy of love you don't
think you're wrong you don't think
you're worthy of love so if people
compliment me i can't take compliments
and if people are like i really love you
i'm like you're confused you're wrong i
might because there's so many people out
there who are better than me yeah why
would you love me i might uh your
because they're not perfect either yeah
like no one's perfect like i've done a
lot of therapy
yeah and they were literally like amy
because of my background they're like
love to you is very transactional
from what my history they're like love
is transactional
it's very tumultuous it's very like i
think love is transactional oh yeah i
think like like everyone brings value to
even a friendship or relationship like
you're people yeah most people aren't
going to stay if you're adding no value
to their life but then that depends on
your self-worth so the past year a
really good friend of mine you're just
like you're self-worth what does that
mean i don't get that so if if i believe
yeah you know what i'm a catch yeah i
believe that i've been so it's like
confidence yeah okay self-assuredness
and recently i'm like
i'm i'm not curing cancer i'm not going
to the moon if anything it's that middle
ground between
it's like being okay with being average
like most people are average i tell my i
tell people i'm like i'm average and
then like guys will be like but you're
not and it's like i'm not curing cancer
i'm not going to the moon yeah however
like it's that middle ground between
being self-assured and self-confident
but being humble when did average become
a bad thing yeah most people are average
no one of the quotes i love to like i
learned is like we can all believe that
we or someone we're dating yeah is one
in a million yeah but then you've got to
be like we're one of a million yeah over
a million it's just i know i'm very
replaceable yeah yeah yeah it just it
almost sounds like even when you were
telling me about not wanting having kids
like it seems like it's almost like a
fear like a fear mindset a little bit
yeah yeah because i don't think it's
because i don't think i could provide
for a kid i don't think i could i don't
think i could match up so i'm like i'd
rather just not put a kid through that
yeah because i'm very compassionate
no i'd rather i'd be like
no
but um
yeah i'd rather like never say never
yeah
yeah i have a question for the ladies on
the panel yeah do you think you could
love a man unconditionally no
yeah i think if i'm being honest no
why do you say no no because if he
murdered somebody i would leave sas okay
yeah like i'd be out
oh no if you had bundied me oh no
that's a condition that's a good point
do you do you think men can love women
unconditionally
um
i i think
more so than women can but i do think
that if a girl was 500 pounds
the guy would be less attached to her he
would be less attached sexually yeah
yeah romantically yeah well you see all
these podcasts recently though like if
my wife gains weight like when she's
pregnant all that stuff but but men
don't leave yeah they don't most of them
stay and so i saw a thing recently like
and this comes back to the like research
that i did when i did like my degree and
it was like um
women again quality over quantity but
men will actually
tend to get to a point where they're
like oh [ __ ] i actually need to settle
down and actually so they actually won't
they will men will actually settle which
is a really unpopular opinion yeah
because they'll get to a point where
they're like oh [ __ ] you know what i've
been seeing it done it all everyone else
is settling down she'll do she works
with what i want do you think men settle
because they're more realistic and women
are unrealistic
so like like women we kind of lie to
each other well massive romantic as well
well and we and we lie to each other
like we'll say lizzo is hot when come on
like
you're laughing because you know exactly
what i'm saying i know yeah i know
you're right like you you get more
attention because you're you're thin
right oh 100 yeah yeah pretty privileged
is a real thing the halo effect is a
real thing right right there's a reason
i dressed up for tonight there's a
reason there's a reason yeah and which
is which is all good and well but like
will we tell our friend that
no no
you try and be a good person you're
trying to be supportive but
like the the facts speak for themselves
yeah
itself like yeah yeah are less attracted
to a big unless they've got like a kink
for it men are less attracted to a
bigger woman but i think like we almost
like lie to girls and say don't settle
don't settle but like you have to settle
on something
like yeah like you gotta i mean if
you're not perfect you can't expect the
person you date
i i
i don't believe
that there's such a thing as settling
and what i mean is this
like
as human beings we're quite
selfish we always choose what we feel is
the best option yeah
so if you choose someone
right
that was the best option you have
because that's not you settling that's
like saying oh i settled to go to
reading university instead of going to
oxford it's like well you didn't get an
offer from oxford so you're not settling
for reading you just didn't get you
didn't have the option that you wanted
so like i don't believe there's actually
a thing called settings sounds like the
people that went to a d3 school in the
usa
i'm very familiar with this
so
but again this comes from this whole
like black and white thinking ideology
of like there's a right way there's
wrong way there's about real worse it's
like actually very few things in life
are right or wrong black white and when
you become comfortable with that middle
path that gray area
like there just is what there is
and so
like what do you mean with what
with any with everything and anything
there's a great there's a middle path
there's a gray yeah being comfortable
with this is what i prioritize or i
think is right yeah so i don't use the
word should anymore because there's a
lot of ideas of what you should be it's
like
compared to who where did that come from
and so i'm like there just is they're
just so i just i need to kind of an
example
um okay so i'm 27. i don't have a career
i get i
i was a very gifted kid and everyone was
like she's gonna go to cambridge she's
gonna um
she's gonna be a doctor she's gonna be a
lawyer i am [ __ ] none of those things i
graduated six years ago for my degree
and i am definitely untapped potential
and if i think about what i should be in
the eyes of others i'm a failure if they
if i think about why i am i am the
happiest i've ever been and so it's like
again well it's that kind of success
thing and it's like